coming up on the next exciting episode
of even bridged commander Ikari
discusses more ideas it's for you to be
for your two key I have another
brilliant idea what is it this time sir
wait what's that thing you always say my
head's full of shits that's the one
nerve came up with their latest genius
plan to defeat the angel I have the
perfect idea why did we use ddr to fight
the angels are you serious no cuz that's
a brilliant idea
no no no seriously let's just be Shinji
has more father-son bonding time hey
Shinji you want to go back to the
highway I've never even been to cuz
that's where most accidents happen
hahahahaha
I don't get it ask your mother oh yeah
know it interesting characters are
introduced Rock that's not a duck right
shows us more of our exciting
personality and finally Oscar shows up
and [ __ ] really hits a fan I'm saying
yes all these scenes will be coming to
you soon even fridge 2.0 holy all the
anime zone and of course there'll be
plenty of fanservice does this mean I
self to do more reviews getting better
views
nobody cares about your stupid internet
Perry's oh [ __ ] you too is she okay I
don't know what is that even me